and we continue to follow breaking news
right now firefighters have been
battling a blaze at a walmart here in
the valley it's near mcleod and
tropicana it seems to have started less
than two hours ago victoria saha there
joining us live with the latest victoria
we understand that fire tampered down
now
yeah brian we found out that the fire
actually started with a tractor trailer
in the back side of the delivery portion
of walmart now i did speak to some
employees of course they were not
allowed to speak with me on camera but
they did share some information on
camera they said it started around 4 30.
they did smell smoke one employee said
that she saw black smoke over the roof
of this walmart here they said that
about a hundred people were inside the
store they didn't say over the
loudspeaker for everyone to evacuate
they just simply said it was code red
and they had to individually tell
everyone that they needed to evacuate i
also did speak to some people who are
waiting outside i did find out that
phallus and ross dressed for less were
also evacuated the clark county fire
department told me that no
injuries were reported and that the fire
crew will be here all night trying to
clean up it's obviously not clear yet if
they will or when they will be reopened
here at walmart reporting live victoria
saha live local now